地下室の演出進撃かよマジでそうなんです
こんにちははじめしたよね黄色の動画で
発見されたんですけども口にマジで知ら
なかったんですけど
地下室がありました
それがそこ差が大きいというか広いやつ
あいあの機能の動画見て下さったらわかる
と思うんですけれどもあの各レーンも各で
もの日本代表のプロにちょっとかくれんぼ
を吸ったら角でもの方が地下室に隠れてて
ええええっ知らないんですよ白が処女見た
ことまで見たことない聞いたこともない前
住んでたオーナーさんから話を聞いたこと
ない間林大地も知らない
知らない部屋
弾いポッターと秘密の部屋 why よ
もう待つ進撃の巨人で隠された地下室だよ
ただでさえ4階建てて大きいのにこの
3億円の家にはなんとをせられていない
地下室がありました
てーしょんあげっ保冷はテンション上がる
わそう月艇仕上がってるじゃんと
かくれんぼして覚円峰の時は隠れてる人を
見つけるためだけにしたおりたんで
ちゃんと見てないんですよまだなんだよの
政府が日彼がどうなっているかとかどう
いう披露さんなのか僕もまだ知れません
あとポロッとかくれんぼのプロが入ってい
たのがもう一個地下ありますよみたいな
ことを言ってたような気がするんですよ
本当かどうかちょっとはならないんです
けども白でちょっと行っ俺の中であっ
ビッグイベントすぎてまた部屋あるんだ
みたいなまだほんの3軒の家にはかなぜが
あるんだと思ってめっちゃテンション
上がっております今ちょっと怖いです君付
金は何か化されてるんじゃないかなと思っ
ちゃうして早速ちょっと濃いんですけども
誰も知らなかった秘密の地下室行ってみ
たいと思いますで5
アルミ9位
大抵でちょっと外から見ていきましょう
うんいえねこれこれレンジね馬車入ります
よと思いますよはシンプルに入口ですよね
入りますはいあげますよんぢゃあこっ
ローカー殺さが開きます
きっ
[音楽]
分けました
ここです
くっそピントずれですけど今回酸っぱい
開きました
ここでこれよ
これねどう見てもさあないやんまいんあっ
たとしてもさ開けてたちょっとこうなんか
伸びも入るかなぁ暗い場所するものを入れ
たりとか何か入れられた場所だと思ったら
知ったカッツリ部屋だったかちょっと開け
ましょうかさ宜しくお願いしますなんで誰
も気づかなかったんじゃないですか
明けな一緒にあんまり
[音楽]
どうやってあげたん秋れない体でもし
なかったがあるああ
うわぁ
こちらです深さ3ているカメラでん
不幸音が完了椅子付言ってませんでした
多分しないと登ってこれぐらい深いた方ね
階段とホント何といけないぐらいの深さが
あったな
なんてなんて何て言っ
神様があったあと教えてだけに教えてって
いう岐阜インテンション上がるよねとして
いっ
ん
[音楽]
the 行ってきますおりません怖いわ
そんなに何か良いから通す降って倒し
ましょうそうかいなかったら助けている何
かあれば
上強い for free
koa そんな不快って頃凄い伊勢って
これこれけっこうマジ良い
4日
いっす ai は時まで早いで心美
ストールのやばいでしょ僕はきたわかるん
ですけど彼がまだちょっとやり初めてみ
たいと思いますどうぞ
[音楽]
ん
よおおおおお
うそー
すごいよねーすごい
すごー
都合
the high level これが
秘密の使って全然1済みそうじゃねこの広
さ言っていけるパーセントを間違いに住ん
でたセンサーですけどなーんてかああいう
路線で置いてるようなんだけどこれ
つくんですこれ
ついたら why けどねでも遠い
ましょうみんなよね間違えてきています
全然寝るもんねこのスペース
そして皆さん
さらにスゴイのか
yeah
もう1本使う五湖
細いけどまずいじるんじゃねーぞまさに
強い5
ここはやっぱりん
まあを使えそうはじめ9時からに同じ服
しか寝れもう
建物を言ってるよを2m くらいから
チャイていますいってらっしゃい
俺の狭いんだなぁ
確かにこの農家の地下室はもっとせ前
ずっと狭いん
1万言ってらっしゃるん
なあは超えてコック0とこ攻めていったよ
きますね
いきます知ってらっしゃい
[音楽]
いきますね行ってらっしゃるん
移動小宇宙子はへよう
俺になんでこんなことだわー
入所
[音楽]
もう一個に地下室ですね
そんなに広くはないです
なマンションによくあるトイレの大きさ
ぐらい
善恵けい合意
は c すごいよねそういやすごいな
パワーをつかむが短柄がうっていう謎を
やってます
あれじゃないこれ
水たまった時を見てああああなるほど
なるほど垂れる
rt ドア
多数がに多分水没とか3ヶ月たまった時の
8月ないか本当に広くして中茶水ことだけ
じゃないけど水が流れやすくしているのも
組も使えした
なんかそんな気がするそれじゃないと本当
に広くは作るの位置がする
なるほどもう版でめっちゃあーこれのいい
よそうですけど
カニ缶追うたびにこんないらんよと思う
こんだけは言われてことはたぶんそういう
では津波とかめちゃくさがり2人で家に水
が溜まったりするもし仮に起きたときに
ここである程度擦れるじゃないかわかん
ない管理人がきました電場こんな色を
2 h4倍米倉 a のってど
これはたり作るさんて関大きさビット
レートがあるじゃないかと思ってなかった
対応
町痴漢は終わってるパーシー胸に誓ったし
そう
さっき別名にもってな
妹笑顔3
[音楽]
すごいん
ふーんへー
ana 2
ani
すごい所
第二凄いっしょとれねー
4を
はぁ
[音楽]
いいいい
う派手でしょ的なこんばんはー
おらぬ
[音楽]
padi これよねぇー
これあ
これじゃねぇ
そ
4早
絶対コレだよね多分1でございわけですで
も the あっちだ誰もつながってな
いっぽいよでいくのか確かに確かめた
開けさせてもらいます
ni
[音楽]
何ないなんかあるけどそのこっちのが綺麗
なんかを
所下り降りる
降りてみませんか
もどってもらえるから
果たして一回入ってからから問い詰めて
からじゃん
異型
いそこは1回でほらこれは何コレ分でいい
ですよね本当に土台なんじゃないのバ
コーンで中にがかしたいとか言ってどう
するのこわいい
は塗
[音楽]
じゃあ行きますってらっしゃいっ失礼し
ます
高
なんでいたらどうしようマジ怖い記載たろ
そくなって見たことないですかねお前は
そんなロー見ていきます
[音楽]
いってらっしゃい
もう
狭いなぁフォンってないわけじゃないけど
はい6枚目だった
なるほど
エスメスを使う
人集まれー
1型のトイレ
なるほどね
ああ
[拍手]